NUMBERS.
KUEMPER HAS WON FIVE IN A ROW H
THREE-ASSIST GAME.
HE WILL RIM IT IN.
BOUNCES AWAY WERE JOUSTING.
JOHNSON LOST WILL CERTAINLY BE
MEMORABLE.
HE WILL TAKE ESSENTIALLY JOE
PAVELSKI, TWO, COLORADO
AVALANCHE, NO SONS
DEFENSIVELY, MORNING
SKATES TO WORK ON HIS SHOT.
IT'S NEUTRAL ICE. HEISKANEN IN
THE DALLAS BENCH.
IT'S CHIPPEDT ON THE LEFT
SIDE.
HE WILL RIM IT AROUND.
PETERSON ABLE TO HELP IT OUT TO
ROROPASS FOR -- LINDELL TURNS.
IT'S ICING AGAIN HIS LAST.
>> Josh: STRETCH PASS.
GETS AWAY FROM.
FAKSA.
THE STARS' PK HAS BEEN
OUTSTANDING THESE LAST IN
IS TRACING
HIM TO THE NET.
>> Daryl: THEY KEEP DOING THE
SAME THING A TIP.
KU
BRACES FOR CONTACT.
HE WILL IN 2021. YEAR,
28%, AVS' PENALTY KILL IS NEAIN.
PAVELSKI, ACROSS FOR RADULOV. I
ANTICIPATED.
NOT THE CASE SO FAR HALFWAY
REDIRECTED T T
>> Daryl: SEGUIN.
SUTER, TOPTINUALLY WORK
THE PUCK THROUGH THE SLOT AREA
FROM ONE BIG D, THE BIG
BLACK BAND COMBINATION OF A
FORWARD AND A DEFENSEMAN, HIS
ABILITY TO DOS RANTANEN.
FROM THAT, THEY FROM THE TIME-O.
REMAIN SIX-ON-FIVE.
EMPTY NET.
IT HAS BEEN THAT WAY OVER A LAN
DOES IT GO  AS IT'S BROUGHT
BACK IN.
>> Daryl: THAT'S GOOD